foreign
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the meeting the audit governance
committee on Tuesday the 22nd of June
we go straight into the apologies for
absence thank you chair apologies from
councilor Ford
thank you very much Kirsty
on to the Declaration of interests
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest when the item is
considered
item 3 agreements of agenda items part
one and two we have no part two
item four urgent matters brought forward
with the permission of the chair I have
no items to bring forward
and none other from the officers
so I will move
to item five
2021-22 statement of accounts and try
annual review of pension and that's
Pages three to seven on the agenda pack
and I'll pass you on to our section 151
officer
for his report thank you David yeah
thank you Chad
um it's a fairly brief report well I'll
just um run through it for you
um so for
2021-22 statement accounts we published
our draft account on our website on the
30th of June which is in line with the
statutory regulations and guidance
the deadline for the external audit of
the accounts was the 30th of November
2022.
and the council's external Auditors did
not meet this deadline and as I've just
said today the 2020 122 account remained
on sign despite several assurances from
Grant Thornton that signed off was
intimate and I've just got two extracts
in the report there from the auditing
governments on the 25th of October an
auditing governance on the 17th of
January so they're minuteed within Arden
governance committees with Grant
Fontaine that they're just about to sign
the accounts off but just to let you
know there was over communication direct
to officers where it was indicated that
um to sign off the 2122 account was
literally days away
so every three years there's a
tri-annual review of Pensions
and and the actually what they do is
they review the assets held by the
pension fund the future liabilities of
the pensions of payments to exist in
pensioners Engineers deferred pensions
Etc
and the assessment of the future cross
the pension benefits which takes into
account contribution required to fund
all the past service and the future
service liabilities of the penthouse
basically looking how much is the
pension fund got which is going into the
pension fund and how much is expected to
be paid out
so arising from the latest Trend review
it meant that the employer's pension
contribution rolled from 17.5 to 19.5
and what's called the secondary rate
which is a contribution the council
makes the underlying deficit
basically we're paying just over half a
million pounds for the next three years
but setting that aside the impact of the
trial review on the 2021-22 account is
when they undertake the review of the
pension liabilities and fund and assets
they take um they calculate based on
asset values and liabilities as of the
31st of March 2022 which is actually
technically the last day of the
financial year 2021-22.
so what was happening wasn't prepared
the accounts were going to be signed off
on the 4th of April 2023 by Grand fund
and we had a meeting of the audience
governance committee and the day before
the triangle review was published Grant
Thornton made the decision to suspend
all sign-offs of 2122 accounts pending a
review of the impact of the triangle
review of Pensions if our accounts have
been signed off on time
um there would be no issue we won't
reopen the account for this trial and
review and this hasn't occurred before
because it's never been so delayed
we saw some guidance from Grant Thornton
um
guidance was a holding partner wait and
see where they'll investigate Etc
however we're starting to do the 2020 to
23 accounts
and in order to do the 22 2223 account
we need a report from the actuary and
the actor he needed to know where we
were going to restate the 2021-2 account
to take into account the triangle review
or not on in order not
2022-23 22 23 accounts uh we told the
actuary wouldn't be restating the
accounts and to proceed on that basis
so after Chasing and Grant fountain for
further guidance in June which failed to
provide a clear direction of travel we
saw independent third party advice from
a company called ichibald
um in a shop called Steven Sheen who
basically are the district councils
within the sort of Devon Somerset area
subscribed to
and some guidance was obtained from
Stephen that's listed in the report but
the
um the main ones I want to bring your
attention to is
first off he says please pension
liabilities would exceed the council's
usual materiality levels the pension
figures are in themselves in terms of
pure figures are amongst the biggest
figures that are in our statement
accounts
um the only thing that comes close is
probably the valuations of our land and
property
however it is questionable after 15
months if any use of the accounts will
do make into a waiting to make a
decision based upon pension figures and
this is the important point which do not
feed into the council's financial
management Arrangement so when we do the
quietly budget monitoring
we don't ever include anything about
future pension liabilities or reserves
we do obviously have the employers
liabilities in there but none of these
figures that would change in terms of
balances on the pension fund ever appear
in our management accounts which is what
we do to make decisions
uh external Auditors may claim that any
potential misstatementist material if it
exceeds their Benchmark figures however
this could be challenged it doesn't seem
it's easy to ignore the advice of the
National Audit offers
so and there's a quote there from the
National Audit office try and train your
reviews are prepared on a different
basis to ISA 19 figures using different
discount rates meaning the two are not
directly comparable as a result and
given their level of inherent
uncertainty the passage in time and the
pressing need to eliminate the backlog
of delayed audits so this delayed audit
we've got
there's hundreds up and down the country
that haven't already haven't been signed
off it would disruportionate and of
little or no benefit for user account to
seek to reproduce and subsequently order
updated when it says ASI pension figures
essentially
so we Stephen gives a proposed
compromise solution a compromised
solution would be to leave the 2021-22
stem accounts as they are but to include
a declosure not explaining why the
figures are now out to date
for the pensions and describing the
substantial differences revealed in the
updated battery report this would hope
to mean the Auditors can Inc include any
emphasis of matter paragraph in their
audit report and the accounts are true
and fair if users are made aware of this
particular disclosure the rest of the
report is some follow-up information
from Super which is like the regulatory
body for
um
it's annual statement accounts within
the local Authority sector which kind of
is it
um but just to go to the conclusions
the draft 2021 statement Council been in
draft Farm since 30th of June 2020
essentially One calendar year and due to
delayed by the external Auditors
compounded by the third of April
publication of the actual real viewer
pensions
given that time has passed and the
optimal solution would not be to restate
the
2022-122 account but and to include a
note as reckon recommended by Stephen
Sheen within the 2021-22 disclosures
it should be noted that pension figures
included in the statement counts arising
from the trial and review either pension
reserve and the pension over the other
two big figures don't impact upon the
decision-making of the council they're
not included within our monitoring on
medium term Financial account and the
reason being they're not usable Reserves
so if the pension deficit hasn't goes up
by 20 million there's a corresponding
entry of a pension Reserve that goes up
by 20 million we don't have to make 20
million pounds worth of savings to the
Council budget to to bridge that when it
talks about the secondary rate early in
the report that's what we have to do we
put some money aside in the to the
underlying payment of the underlying
deficit which is calculated on some
completely different basis so really
we're just looking for support from this
committer to not restate the
2021-22 accounts
um I suspect we may potentially get some
feedback or rollback maybe from the
external archers on this approach what
we don't know at this stage
okay
thank you very much indeed David for
a very clear Report with logical
conclusions
would I be right in assuming that this
report has been
emailed to Grant Martin it is a public
document well they're on the circulation
they are the circulation list so there
is every belief that they would have
seen this and had the opportunity to
comment which they clearly haven't
we haven't received any apologies today
no
that's what I've been so so there's
something I probably should have said as
well is that
it's quite a substantial piece of work
to restate because whilst these figures
have no
impact on decision making so if you
looked at our um
statement accounts he looked at the
balance sheet certain figures alive one
of the one would be the usable reserves
that is money that's girls probably sat
in the council's bank account because
we've set sided money in previous years
that's a tangible thing
um debtors what we owe people sorry debt
is what was owed to us so we've got
invoices out there for Beach Huts say
for example and people always wanted to
pay for the Bishops their tangible
meaning of all things the pension
reserve and the pension availability are
not in terms of they're not real and
they don't impact on the day-to-day
decision making of the council but their
impact spreads for the figures will
change throughout the council be
substantial piece of work both when
obviously I'm leaving assuming um
another colleague who leaves at the end
of July
um she's responsible for pulling
together the account so there's also a
work and resource issue over and above
this this year frustration that we've
got to this point because
promises that were made to the council
haven't been capped
yeah I think there is only
don't quote me but I think there was
only two the Devon authorities that had
their accounts signed off and I think
Plymouth
may not add the accounts from the
previous year signed up it's a national
issue in terms of the
public sector audit markets is not
functioning as it should be they have
troubles recruiting staff out and they
have trouble retaining
staff
and so they don't they've not been
resourcing
um public sector audits basically
and they will actually quote that
they've actually completed slightly more
percentage of audits than other firms
but it's from a
this isn't a situation this situation
wasn't four or five years ago this
wasn't the norm for local government
which I always in terms of what
councilor Brendan mentioned I know the
LGA are acutely aware of the situation
it was it was uh written in the
municipal Journal as well I think it was
last week or the the week before so
there's hundreds of authorities in this
uh position
um but ultimately if that's a decision
of the the committee we'll let our
regional advisor away for the report so
he can ensure it gets fed into the
correct channels
okay
um
please
microphone on
um alternatives
that's the question
one of the Alternatives would be wait
for grunt get Farm to give us a
definitive steer
rework the 2120 accounts which would be
changing up the figures where the
pension could it so I'm struggling to
articulate just how it would change just
because
it would change
the income and expenditure
but it wasn't changing kind of
expenditure now
profit and loss that you can tangibly
touch you'd change it because there's a
Nuance of council statement of accounts
which is then don't follow what normal p
l would be within the prime sector so
essentially it'd be we'd have to
work through the impact of it once we've
got clear Gardens from Grant Thornton
have a direction of travel
okay
would also have to the accounts that are
literally going to be published tomorrow
for the draft
2022-23 accounts we'd have to revisit
them because the starting point would be
different
and all I suppose what I'm trying to say
is who is the user of the count who was
going to make a decision differently
because of this pension this isn't a
they say um another Council which is
based in say a section 114 notes where
within the figures is a really important
thing about saying how much borrowing
they've got and can they meet their
ongoing liabilities going forward it's
not that issue it's just a
it would change figures in the council
one of them it's clear in its name
non-usable Reserves
for you so the pension Reserve is
non-usable it's not by cash
no I understand I must admit my question
was less about the Alternatives in
operations
alternatives to the auditing company but
you did mention that others are in the
same boat shall we say yeah I mean
and they compromise proposal from
Stephen Sheen it talks about a matter of
emphasis ultimately a audio firm could
qualify the accounts
and say they don't represent a true and
Fairview they've ultimately always got
that sanction if they believe that you
know so I think well coming to you as a
committee was is to get the support
that the members are pretty understand
what's being asked of them I mean they
could ultimately qualify the council I
don't think it would come to that but I
can't speak for them
usually I think I thought Council Gibson
was asking about alternatives to Grand
Thornton as a company rather than and
that that decided certain process but
yeah okay
right well
I'm going to thank you for all the work
you've done on this David
and really
torridge is being asked in some ways to
pay for the failure
of our Auditors in Grant Thornton
I think that would be a fair enough
statement to make
it's quite reprehensible that we have
been promised
that we would have these accounts signed
off meeting after meeting and I even had
an assurance
from the auditor
who has not turned up today either
virtually or in person
to say that
she would let me know if there was going
to be yet another delay and that hasn't
happened
I'm going to move from the chair
the following recommendation that
members support the council in not
restating
the 2021-22 statement of accounts
and that the chair of autumn government
writes to both the public sector audit
appointments body and Grant Thornton
detailing the Cancer's position
do I have a seconder
thank you David David Brenton second all
those in favor
unanimous it can't be Kirsty
right
um
we have no part six item
or part seven
thank you everybody for turning up and
finally my thanks to you David for your
role
as section 151 officer for this Council
it's been an absolute privilege to work
forward with you I feel like I've had
More Goodbyes in Frank Sinatra to be
honest with you
are you making a comeback
I believe there's a role of auditor
um but you know I'm sure we all wish you
the very best for the future I know you
had a round of applause
we're somewhat sparse here today no we
don't do that but um okay I hope your
golf handicap comes down from the group
on that one thank you thank you right
thanks everybody I'm closing the meeting
at
219. thank you